Hey David, what would a gun control compromise
look like between left and right?
Okay, let's do this.
But we have to agree on a parameter first
because otherwise we're not going to get anywhere.
Given that the second amendment exists, what
would a compromise look like if we are really
going to imagine a compromise that ignores
that the second amendment exists, even if
you don't like the Second Amendment, even
if you wish.
The second amendment didn't exist.
We won't get anywhere in imagining a compromise
that assumes the second amendment doesn't
exist, so we actually have to account for
that.
When we think about what a gun safety compromise
might look like between left and right, but
I actually think there's a bigger problem
that we have to talk about.
We could rattle off policies.
I could say, well the rite could concede universal
background checks and maybe we would ban some
high capacity magazines and the left would
have to concede something else.
Then we would just argue about whether that's
too far left or too far right or too extreme.
We would get nowhere.
In reality though, because there's a bigger
issue when you talk about a gun safety compromise.
The problem here is not a practical problem.
We could get together and workshop ideas and
come to some kind of hypothetical compromise
where both sides would give some stuff up
and get something and everybody would be sort
of unhappy, which is often the way a good
compromise ends up.
The problem is we can't actually have that
conversation in good faith because number
one, everyone will see the compromise as a
Trojan horse and then immediately imagine
that the other side is going to just try to
get more and use the compromise as a way to
move the needle slightly.
And number two, you have a very well funded
market altering players like the NRA that
are a direct impediment to actually having
good faith conversations about this stuff.
So it's actually a completely intractable
conversation.
The causes of gun violence need to be addressed.
The availability of guns needs to be addressed.
Mental health sure needs to be addressed.
Gun Culture, the religion of guns is a massive
problem in the United States and for good
reason, no one trusts the other side to negotiate
in good faith.
I'm not doing both sides.
Ism, okay.
The pro gun, more guns and more places side
is disgusting and they are extremely well
funded by these uh, gun manufacturers through
groups like the NRA.
But whatever lists you and I can come up with
right now about what a compromise would look
like is effectively dead on arrival.
Because groups like the NRA are very good
at getting even Donald Trump to say, oh I
was for background checks.
Yeah, we're not doing that anymore.
And number two, if you can seed anything,
the other side will say that's not in good
faith.
You're just doing this in order to in six
months push for more and we're not going to
allow it.
And this is unfortunately one of the areas
in which I am most pessimistic gun safety.
I've talked already about climate change.
If you've been watching the show, you know
that I am not particularly optimistic on the
climate.
Gun Safety is another area where I am not
at all optimistic that we are going to make
it happen in a huge reason for that is the
just corrosive and disgusting effect of organizations
like the NRA.
Uh, and I, I want to be convinced that this
could happen.
I really do.
But look at what happened with background
checks after Sandy Hook.
Look at all of the other examples.
Uh, so I am not particularly optimistic and
I think whatever list we could come up with
would be taking an immediate back seat to
the partisan and lobbied in monied lobbying
interests that exist within gun safety.
Let me know if I'm wrong and I should have
some more optimism on this.
We've got a great bonus show coming up for
you today.
Become a member or
patron to get instant access@joinpacman.com
or patrion.com/david [inaudible], the David
Pakman show@davidpakman.com.